ich rufe nun die soeben aufgesetzten
Zusatzpunkte 14 und 15 auf erste
Beratung des von der Bundesregierung
eingebrachten Gesetzentwurfs zur
Änderung des Gebäude Energiegesetzes zur
Änderung der Heizkostenverordnung und
zur Änderung der kehr- und
überprüfungsordnung sowie Beratung des
Antrags der Fraktion Die Linke mit dem
Titel Abschaffung der
Modernisierungsumlage zum Schutz der
Mieterinnen und Mieter für die
Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von 68
Minuten beschlossen
ich eröffne die Aussprache und zuerst
hat das Wort für die Bundesregierung der
Bundesminister für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz dr Robert Habeck ja der
Wirtschaftsminister als erster Redner zu
diesem Gesetz was ja am Dienstag noch
mal durchaus deutlich verändert wurde
durch die Koalitionäre
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren danke dass dieses Gesetz
aufgesetzt wurde ich denke es ist
tatsächlich zumindest debattierreif aus
meiner Sicht dann auch entscheidungsreif
das ist ja nicht so es ist ja nicht so
das ist geheim gewesen wäre was in
diesem Gesetz steht sondern Deutschland
hat sich ja intensiv damit befasst und
die Fraktion natürlich auch lassen Sie
mich lassen Sie mich die Debatte mit
einem Zitat wenn Erlaubnis der
Präsidentin der von mir persönlich sehr
geschätzten ehemaligen Bundeskanzlerin
beginnen um vielleicht deutlich zu
machen was das Problem ist bzw was das
politische Problem ist Frau Merkel sagte
als sie ein Klimaschutzpaket der damals
großen Koalition vorstellte politik ist
die Kunst des Möglichen das macht man so
sehen aber es ist natürlich eine
Beschränkung in der Ambition was diese
Regierung in den letzten 15 Monaten
gezeigt hat ist das Politik die Kunst
ist möglich machen ist wir haben
wir haben
als ich Minister wurde eine
klimaschutzlücke von
1.100 Millionen Tonnen CO2 bis 2030
geerbt wir haben sie durch die
beschlossenen eingeleiteten Maßnahmen um
70% reduziert und können Sie mit den
verabredeten Maßnahmen um 80% auf 200
Millionen Tonnen kumuliert bis 2030
reduzieren das liegt daran dass
[Applaus]
wir mit Abstrichen aber mit
Entschiedenheit Gesetze vorangebracht
haben Punkte angegangen sind in 15 16
Monaten die 16 Jahre lang liegen
geblieben
sind das
und das gilt in besonderen Maße auch für
die Gasversorgung wenn man mit hohem
Druck die gaskapazitäten aus Russland
nicht nur ausbaut sondern verdoppelt
Nord Stream 1 und Nordstemmen 2 wenn man
bis wir in die Regierung eingetreten
sind die Neueinbau von Gasheizung auch
noch finanziell also mit Steuergeld
wahrscheinlich mit Schulden finanzierten
Steuergeld fördert dann darf man sich
natürlich nicht wundern wenn die Politik
des Möglichen sehr begrenzt nur
umgesetzt wird deswegen hat Johannes vor
gerecht wie sollte mit der Politik des
Möglichen jemals das ja verabredete
Klimaschutzziel erreicht werden wie
sollte ist rechnerisch denkt logisch
möglich sein wenn man den Einbau von
neuen Gasheizung die er Fossil betrieben
werden fördert ohne die Umkehrung
einzuleiten sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren damit ist natürlich auch gesagt
Politik ist möglich machens
das ist ein Spannungsfeld zwischen der
politischen Notwendigkeit und der
gesellschaftlichen Realität geben kann
sonst wäre es ja sinnlos über
Möglichkeiten zu reden dann könnte man
ja entlang von Excel-Tabellen alles
mögliche machen nun wie war die
gesellschaftliche Notwendigkeit im
letzten Jahr und über den letzten Winter
noch über Weihnachten und die
Weihnachtstage war die Realität dass
eine gasmangelage droht das Unternehmen
uns zu Haufen geschrieben haben dass Sie
bitte nicht abgeschaltet werden sollte
uns das Gas ausgehen und die logische
Konsequenz ist dass jede neue eingebaute
Gasheizung das Problem vergrößert hätte
und hat diesem Eindruck und es war ein
breit geteilter Eindruck in der
Gesellschaft hat diese Koalition sich
entschieden den Koalitionsvertrag
verabredeten Zeitpunkt von 25 auf 24
nach vorne zu ziehen der
Koalitionsausschuss in März 22 die
Regierung mit dem Kabinett beschlossen
im April 23 und dann
ist
durch diese Bedrohungslage ist
handhabbar gemacht worden im besten Fall
verschwunden durch eine große gemeinsame
Kraftanstrengung aber das hat die
Debatte verändert deswegen verändert
sich jetzt auch der Gesetzentwurf und
zwar und das ist auch neu und zwar weil
wir die kommunale Werbeplanung
verpflichtend vorsehen über die
Größenordnung der Kommunen werden wir
noch reden aber
verpflichtend vorsehen und das damit so
wie dargestellt ändert sich der Eingang
in das Gesetz der Kern des Gesetzes die
dekarbonisierung der Dame nicht mehr
immer neue Öl und Gasheizung einbauen
der bleibt erhalten aber der Eingang
ändert sich weil sich einerseits die
gesellschaftliche Notwendigkeit oder
gesellschaftliche Debatte verändert hat
natürlich richtigerweise zuzugeben und
gleichzeitig wir andere Möglichkeiten
geschaffen haben damit verzahn wir damit
verzahn wir die kommunale wärmeplanung
mit dem Gebäude Energiegesetz so hier
ist der leitplankenbeschluss der
Fraktionsvorsitzenden gestern oder der
Fraktion gestern vorsieht und damit
lösen wir ein zweites Problem ein
gestuften Einstieg in das Gebäude
Energiegesetz bzw in die Art des heizen
denn es ist ja so dass viele gerade
großen Städte schon wärmepläne haben es
ist so dass viele Bundesländer bereits
wärmeplan Gesetze haben die sind schon
auf dem Weg die werden 24 vielleicht 25
fertig sein es ist ja nicht so dass bis
28 gar nichts passiert sondern es geht
jetzt es geht jetzt
allmählich in das Gesetz und damit lösen
wir auch die Fragen die geklärt über die
aufgeworfen wurden als ich darum ging ob
genug Handwerker da sind oder der
Hochlauf von Technik mithält was ich
damit sagen will ist
wir sollten uns ehrlich machen es gibt
ein Spannungsverhältnis es wäre blind
das zu ignorieren aber wir sollten nicht
aufhören dafür zu arbeiten das mögliche
immer wieder zu erweitern und zu machen
dafür zu arbeiten die die Möglichkeiten
die Option
en wie das Land hat zu erweitern und das
haben wir getan und ich freue mich auf
die Beratung vielen Dank
die Bundeswirtschaftsminister mit einer
Erklärung für die Veränderung seines
ursprünglichen Gesetzes interessant war
noch einmal der Hinweis dass die
kommunale wärmeplanung die er jetzt erst
nach vorne tritt bis zu 10.000
Einwohnern gilt die bisher alle die
unter 10.000 Einwohner in Städten wohnen
sind momentan auch davon betroffen dass
ab 1.12 24 dann Heizung eingebaut wurden
müssen die 65 % dich
Erneuerbaren für die Union
Streit
Koalitionspapier gleich am nächsten Tag
wieder Streit neues Papier wieder Streit
die Ampel und das Geld das ist längst
ein running gag nur kein lustiger also
jetzt wieder ein Papier dieses Mal zwei
Seiten Leitplanken zwei Monate nach dem
Kabinett Beschluss das sind Leitplanken
für eine Koalition die längst den Kurs
verloren hat und das ist das eigentliche
Problem in dieser Debatte
das was sie heute machen
das was sie hier heute machen ist und
bleibt eine Fahrt Herr Minister das
Gesetz dass sie hier gerade eingebracht
haben ist nachdem was in diesen
Leitplanken steht das Papier nicht mehr
Wert auf denen es geschrieben ist es ein
Gesetz für die Tonne und deswegen ist es
eine Zumutung für dieses Parlament dass
wir heute für diesen Entwurf meine erste
Lesung machen und es ist übrigens ein
Geheimnis der FDP jetzt muss man ja auch
mal sagen sie haben im Kabinett diesem
Gesetz zugestimmt um anschließend dafür
zu kämpfen dass es eine 180 Grad Wende
gibt wenn man Frust in der Politik
befördern will dann muss man sich genau
so verhalten auch das ist ein Problem
unserer Zeit hier aktuell Politik
gemacht wird
und bei den Leitplanken ist ja nichts
klar Minister Habeck heute morgen im
Radio zu ihren Leitplanken da stehen
sehr viele ungenaue Formulierungen drin
da stehen also noch interessante drei
Wochen vor uns das ist jetzt kein
Gesetzestext ja Herr Minister da haben
Sie Recht und damit haben wir es quasi
regierungsoffiziell der Minister sagt
selbst dass das was wir hier diskutieren
im Grunde noch nicht klar ist und ja
kommen ja alles das nenne ich einen
verkorkstes Verfahren was ist es denn
sonst nachdem der Minister das selbst
heute morgen so gesagt hat
und es ist eine Zumutung dass wir hier
eine erste Lesung machen zu einem Gesetz
das veraltet ist es ist eine Zumutung
dass sie gestern im Ausschuss per
Mehrheit abgeblockt haben dass überhaupt
diskutiert wird über die Leitplanken und
das Gesetz und es ist eine Zumutung dass
sie uns bis jetzt noch nicht zugesagt
haben das nächste Woche Anhörungen
stattfinden sollen wo der neue
Gesetzestexte vorliegen wir sollen eine
Anhörung machen die Experten sollen sich
verhalten zu einem Gesetz das obsolet
ist keiner weiß was jetzt kommt dieses
ganze Verfahren hier in deutschen
Bundestag ist eine Zumutung und der
Würde des Deutschen Bundestages
das hat es in 16 Jahren übrigens nicht
gegeben ein solches erfahren das will
ich auch mal ziemlich klar sagen ja doch
das muss man auch mal dazu sagen ziehen
Sie diesen alten Gesetzentwurf zurück er
hat hier im Deutschen Bundestag keine
Mehrheit er hatte nie eine dass das hier
bis zum Sommer entschieden wird in
zweiter dritter Lesung das ist nur für
die Grüne Partei wichtig das ist nur für
die Gesichtswahrung des Ministers
wichtig es ist für die BürgerInnen
und Klimaschutz aber viel wichtiger dass
wir ein gutes ein vernünftiges ein
fachlich ordentlich beratendes Gesetz
waren das ist das entscheidende und
nicht die Frage ob sie bis zum
Sommerferien sind oder nicht und
deswegen braucht es ein deutliches
Verfahren
und wenn man dann mal hinschaut sind ja
wieder viele Fragen offen wenn ich
nächstes Jahr als Bürger eine Gasheizung
einbaue muss ich die dann 2028 wieder
Einbau ausbauen wenn eine wärmeplanung
da ist sie sagen ja sie sagen nein wird
es vor Einbau einer Gasheizung eine
verpflichtende Beratung geben sagen die
Grünen oder ein Beratungsangebot sagt
die FDP ein ziemlicher Unterschied wird
es eine Förderung geben und wenn ja
welche für wen in welcher Höhe und
technologieoffen Herr Kollege Vogel ich
habe gesagt es ist scheinbar
technologieoffen scheinbar die richtige
Richtung ob es so kommen wird können wir
ja noch gar nicht sagen weil keiner die
Gesetzestexte kennt und das alles zeigt
wir brauchen ein vernünftigen
Gesetzentwurf von mir eine ordentliche
Beratung zu machen sie müssen ja selbst
gar nicht worüber Sie reden
und das eigentliche Problem ist ja noch
viel grundsätzlicher mitten in der Krise
Krieg in Europa
rekordinflation Rezession Migration
Klimawandel mitten in diesen vielen
Krisen streiten sie und streiten und
streiten während der Kanzler ist heute
einmal mehr nicht da während der Kanzler
abtaucht was der eigentlich will weiß
keiner wo ist Olaf möchte man ja sagen
statt OBD während Wut Frust
Polarisierung im Land dramatisch wachsen
falls sie falls sie wirklich verstanden
haben sollten falls sie wirklich
verstanden haben sollten was gerade bei
uns im Land passiert dann kann ich nur
sagen ziehen Sie dieses Gesetz zurück
machen Sie ein ordentliches erfahren
machen Sie ein Verfahren bei dem
Vertrauen wie der wachsen kann und nicht
ein Verfahren bei dem weiter Vertrauen
zerstört wird
stellvertretender Fraktionsvorsitzender
der Union hat gesagt ihr Gesetz ist für
die Tonne sehr viele ungenaue
Formulierungen das ist noch kein
Gesetzestext das aber auch der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister heute im Radio
zugegeben so könnte man hier mit dem
Parlament nicht umgehen
und Bauwesen klarer Gallwitz
e die nächste auch zuständige Minister
nämlich Clara garveitz die
bundeswehrministerin
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren Abgeordneter
der Bundestag berät heute in erster
Lesung das Gebäude Energiegesetzes wie
es vom deutschen Bundeskabinett
verabredet wurde und die Fraktion haben
signalisiert dass sie Veränderungsbedarf
haben sie das als Ausdruck eines
souveränen eines selbstbewussten
Parlamentes
und wunderlich etwas dass diese
Selbstverständlichkeit auch Verwunderung
stößt
ist es wichtig hat er Jens Spahn gefragt
ist es wichtig dass dieses Gesetz
verabschiedet wird ja aus zwei Gründen
zum einen Deutschland hat Heizung wir
diskutieren seit Wochen aufgeregt über
Heizung das ist sicherlich auch eine
Reaktion darauf dass wir über viel zu
lange Zeit nie über Heizung gesprochen
haben
aber es ist natürlich etwas was grob
emotionales was jeden betrifft und
natürlich bei vielen Hausbesitzern die
Frage aufwirft kann ich mir das leisten
wenn ich eine andere Heizung brauche und
es ist aus einem anderen Grund auch noch
wichtig nämlich der Klimaschutz die AFD
hat ja gesagt wir haben kein Problem das
ist sowieso alles nur eine Erfindung und
ich war gestern mit Steffi Lemke in der
Hasenheide ich war in der Hasenheide und
da kann man jetzt schon im Juni sehen
wie die Wiesen vertrocknen wie die
wirken Umfallen wie die Flüsse ja und
sie stellen sich hin und brüllen und
sagen das muss alles gar nicht sein
Liebe Bürger das ist doch gar nicht wahr
das ist ein Problem mit dem Thema gibt
nein das Gegenteil ist der Fall wir
müssen handeln und die Zeit drängt
erheblich weil 20-45 das ist für den
Gebäude Sektor quasi übermorgen und für
ein Austausch dieser riesigen
heizungsflotte ist es eigentlich viel zu
spät
wir sehen das in anderen Ländern das vor
Jahrzehnten in die kommunale
wärmeplanung eingegangen wurde und
Robert Habeck hat darauf verwiesen
natürlich ist die Frage was traut man
sich eigentlich zu mit einer
Gesellschaft zu diskutieren welche
Veränderungen auf uns zukommen damit wir
dieses Ziel 2045 klimaneutral
tatsächlich erreichen da werden wir
Fragen stellen die sehr emotional werden
das heißt wie wird unsere Wirtschaft
aussehen wie werden wir Verkehr
organisieren und ja auch wie heizen wir
und das hat auch die Vorgängerregierung
schon angefasst dieses Gebäude
Energiegesetz ist noch von der großen
Koalition und im Gebäude Energiegesetz
der großen Koalition gab es auch schon
eine Regelung zum heizungsaustausch
und zwar
für 30 Jahre alte konstant
temperaturkessel im Gebäuden der einen
Besitzer diese nach dem ersten Februar
2002 erworben haben das war die Reform
Geschwindigkeit der Vorgängerregierung
und mit dieser Geschwindigkeit werden
wir bis 20 45 niemals klimaneutral im
Gebäudebereich
und das ist ein gewaltiger
Transformationsprozess deswegen bin ich
sehr froh dass wir auch einen Hinweis
bekommen haben von den
Regierungsfraktionen dass sie sich
wünschen dass wir die Worte
Energiegesetz noch viel stärker mit der
kommunalen wärmeplanung aus meinem Haus
und Vorbereitung verknüpfen die
wärmeplanung des Gesetzes jetzt gerade
in der Anhörung mit den Verbänden und es
soll dazu dienen dass die Kommunen einen
Plan machen welche Potenziale sie haben
die man noch nutzen kann an Geothermie
an Abwasserwärme an Abwärme von
vorhandenen
industriebetriebenenzentren etc und dass
sie die Bürger orientieren in welchen
Bereichen ihrer Stadt zum Beispiel eine
zentrale Fernwärmeversorgung geplant
wird und in welchen nicht diese
Verknüpfung ist sehr sinnvoll denn das
was die Menschen wollen ist Orientierung
es geht darum dass wir gemeinsam mit den
Bürgern in diesem Land die
Modernisierung im Heizungskeller
schaffen und zwar verlässlich möglichst
effizient indem wir zentrale
wärmeversorgungssystem ausbauen und am
Anfang sind das große Investitionen die
aber dazu führen dass sie zum ein CO2
einsparen dass wir aber auch eine
effiziente und preisstabile
Wärmeversorgung hinbekommen denn wer
glaubt dass Gas in den nächsten
Jahrzehnten unendlich zur Verfügung
steht und wer glaubt dass Gas und Öl mit
der CO2 Bepreisung so preiswert sind wie
sie vor dem 24 Februar waren der streut
den Menschen Sand in die Augen und
deswegen ist es notwendig dass wir
diesen schwierigen Aushandlungsprozess
ehrlich angehen mit allen Strukturen die
damit einhergehen sich ein schlanken Fuß
zu machen oder einfach nur recht lange
zu rufen löst das Problem leider nicht
herzlichen Dank
die Bundesbahn
widersprach das dieses Gesetz nicht
unbedingt vor der Sommerpause
verabschiedet werden muss sie sagen es
ist dringend notwendig
gibt es einen
Kurzintervention von der Kollegen lei
aus der Fraktion DIE LINKE
ja vielen link
ich bin nicht dazu gekommen meine
Frage bestellen und die Notwendigkeit
kommunaler wärmeplanung ökologischen
wärmewende ist ja das eine aber die
entscheidende Frage bei diesem Gesetz
ist doch auch wie Mieterinnen und Mieter
nicht stärker belastet werden durch
diesen Gesetzentwurf denn sie stehen
doch jetzt schon mit dem Rücken zur Wand
und deswegen müssen wir dafür Sorge
tragen dass Mieterinnen und Mieter nicht
stärker belastet werden unter wirklich
einzige konkrete Vorschlag dauerte
schwarze Meister verfolgt ist unser
Vorschlag nämlich die
Modernisierungsumlage abzuschaffen und
ich habe von der Koalition bisher nur
gehört man wollte Mieterinnen und Mieter
irgendwie weiter entlassen aber es ist
nicht konkretisiert und auch der
Präsident des Deutschen Mieterbundes hat
das Schaf kritisiert und gesagt eine
weitere Modernisierungsumlage ist der
falsche Weg was wir tatsächlich brauchen
ist diese Umlage der sehr
Investitionskosten auf die Mieterinnen
und Mieter abzulehnen und deswegen muss
die Modernisierungsumlage endlich
abgeschafft werden
Frau Ministerin möchten Sie antworten
[Applaus]
gut dafür darüber informiert dass für
Mietrecht der Kollege Buschmann
zuständig ist deswegen habe ich mich in
meinen Ausführungen auf die Werbeplanung
konzentriert für die mein Haus zuständig
ist aber ansonsten ist ihnen ansonsten
ist Ihnen sicherlich klar dass gerade
die Belastbarkeit der Mieterinnen und
Mieter mir sehr sehr wichtig ist und ich
habe das auch den Leitplanken der
koalitionsfraktion entnommen dass dieses
Thema sehr intensiv diskutiert wird und
das wird es sicherlich im weiteren
Gesetzgebungsverfahren auch herzlichen
Dank
nächste Redner in dieser Debatte für die
afd-fraktion Markt Bernhard
ist der baupolitische Sprecher der AFD
[Applaus]
[Musik]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
nach über 2 Monaten Streit in der
Koalition bringen sie heute ernsthaft
ihren
unveränderten Referentenentwurf aus dem
April ein bei dem sie schon selber
festgestellt haben dass er untauglich
und nicht umsetzbar ist das ist ein
Lächerlichkeit nicht mehr zu überbieten
und gestern legen Sie dann zwei Seiten
sogenannte Leitplanken für den
heizungshammer vor und weigern sich
gleichzeitig dem zuständigen Ausschuss
zu erläutern was diese sogenannten
Leitplanken bedeuten und wie sie zu
interpretieren sind der einzig plausible
Grund dafür ist dass sie es selber noch
gar nicht wissen
in den nächsten Sitzungswoche wollen Sie
also eine Expertenanhörung zu einem
Gesetzentwurf Abhalten von dem sie jetzt
schon wissen dass er untauglich und
nicht umsetzbar ist was soll solch eine
unsinnige sinnlose Anhörung sie
verhöhnen so dass Parlament und die
Menschen da draußen in allen Medien
suggerieren sie dass der heizungshammer
angeblich um vier Jahre verschoben wird
das ist schlichtweg falsch denn davon
steht nichts in ihren sogenannten
Leitplanken den Gasheizungen sind nach
wie vor ab 2024 also in sechs Monaten
verboten außer sie können auf
Wasserstoff umgerüstet werden
aktuell gibt es aber nur Gasheizungen
die mit maximal 30% Wasserstoff
betrieben werden können die Umstellung
einer Gasheizung auf 100% wasserstoff
ist laut expertenstand heute schlicht
nicht möglich das was sie hier also in
ihrem sogenannten Leitplanken fordern
ist technisch gar nicht machbar und in
Neubaugebieten dürfen Gasheizungen
überhaupt nicht mehr eingebaut werden
und da sie für Ölheizungen keine
Ausnahmeregelung formuliert haben in
ihrem sogenannten Leitplanken müssen wir
davon ausgehen dass der Einbau komplett
verboten ist außerdem steht heute schon
im Gesetz das Öl und Gasheizungen in der
Regel nach 30 Jahren ersetzt werden
müssen
allein im nächsten Jahr werden sieben
Millionen Öl und Gasheizungen über 30
Jahre alt sein also was hat sich denn
jetzt im Vergleich zu ihrem bisherigen
heizungsshammer Wesentliches verändert
in der Praxis absolut gar nichts der
Einbau von Ölheizungen ist nach wie vor
verboten Gasheizungen können nur
eingebaut werden wenn sie auf
Wasserstoff umgebaut werden können
Anlagen die von Ihnen geforderten 65%
Wasserstoff bei Mischung erfüllen gibt
es stand heute überhaupt gar nicht
und den Neubaugebieten ist der Einbau
von Gasheizungen komplett verboten das
einzige was sie tatsächlich
Wesentliches geändert haben ist das man
auch noch ein verpflichtendes
Beratungsgespräch wie beim
Schwangerschaftsabbruch führen muss
damit man sich überhaupt noch eine
wasserstofftaugliche Heizung kaufen darf
also die Beratung die die Mehrheit von
ihnen beim schwacher beim
Schwangerschaftsabbruch abschaffen will
wo ist meine Entscheidung überleben und
Tod geht die wollen Sie hier jetzt für
den Kauf einer Gasheizung verpflichtend
einführen das ist vollkommen irre
ihre Tiere sogenannten Leitplanken sind
also nichts anderes als ein mediales
Ablenkungsmanöver um den Menschen Sand
in die Augen zu streuen und sie in
falscher Sicherheit zu bieten der
heizungshammer ist nicht verschoben er
kommt und zwar mit voller Wucht in sechs
Monaten
der nächste Redner in der Debatte über
das Gebäuden Energiegesetz hier im
Bundestag in erster Lesung kommt von der
FDP Lukas Köhler er ist der zuständige
fraktions-vize und hat an diesem Gesetz
sehr viel mitgearbeitet
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Aufgabe des Parlaments die Aufgabe
des Parlaments ist kluge Gesetze zu
beschließen das ist der Souverän der das
tut und das machen wir und das heißt wir
diskutieren die Sachen wir haben aber
noch ein zweiter Aufgabe wir müssen hier
darüber diskutieren wie diese Gesetze
gut werden und die Unterschiedlichkeit
darüber was das bedeutet auch klar
machen und wir diskutieren hier darüber
wie wir dieses Gesetz erklärbar machen
weil das ist das was die Menschen von
uns erwarten ein erklärbares Gesetz das
darauf verweist was bedeutet es für mich
dass wir in diesem Land 2045 spätestens
klimaneutral sind das ist die
Herausforderung vor der wir stehen und
das tun wir das tun wir indem wir
miteinander beraten und das tun wir
dadurch dass wir dieses Gesetz das von
der Bundesregierung vorgelegt wurde
jetzt versehen mit Leitplanken eine neue
Richtung drehen dass wir ein wirklichen
erklärbaren Entwurf und dann auch ein
erklärbares gutes Gesetz daraus machen
das ist die Herausforderung vor dir
steht und das ist es was die Leit
Planken und jetzt vorgeben das ist die
Richtung die wir gehen und dann werden
wir ein gutes Gebäude Energiegesetz
machen das ist die Herausforderung
wir kurz erklären woran das hängt ich
glaube der Fokus dieses Gesetzes war
falsch weil er war erst nur rein auf die
Heizung gerichtet auf die Frage welche
Heiztechnologie eingebaut werden muss es
kommt aber ein zweiter ganz wesentlicher
effektivzug denn erst muss der Staat
vorlegen wie soll es mit meiner Heizung
mit meinem Heizsystem vor Ort
weitergeben dazu muss die Kommune eine
wärmeplanung und dann muss der Bürger
darauf abgestimmt frei entscheiden
können was er bei sich einbaut und das
ist die Herausforderung das ist es was
wir jetzt neu schaffen
das ist es warum dieses Gesetz jetzt gut
wird weil die Menschen wissen was sie
bei sich einbauen ob sie Fernwärme
nutzen ob sie eine mit Wasserstoff
betriebene Gasheizung nutzen ob sie Holz
und Pellets einsetzen das ist die
Herausforderung von der besteht und das
klären wir jetzt und das erklären wir
jetzt dadurch dass das ein gutes Gesetz
wird
die Bürger fragen sich in diesem Land
wie geht es weiter und diese Sorge
können wir Ihnen jetzt nehmen natürlich
kommt jetzt ein Gesetz der
Bundesregierung in die erste Lesung
es gibt das sogenannte drucksche Gesetz
das heißt jedes Gesetz dass dieses
diesen Bundestag verlässt sieht anders
aus als es hier reingekommen ist und das
ist es was mit diesem Gesetz passieren
wird natürlich verändern wir das
natürlich nehmen wir die Sorgen der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger ernst und das ist
doch die Herausforderung das ist es was
wir mit diesem neuen Gebäude
Energiegesetz schaffen werden das ist
endlich dafür gesorgt wird dass wir eine
erklärbares Gesetz vorlegen Herr Dr
Köhler apropos Ernst der Kollege Ernst
möchte eine Zwischenfrage stellen wollen
sie die zulassen
danke Herr Dr kühne dass sie die Frage
zulassen sie haben gesagt der Bundestag
hat die Aufgabe dann vernünftige Gesetze
zu machen haben Sie sicher vollkommen
recht das Problem bei diesem Gesetz war
ja nun dass es in einem Zustand ins
Parlament eingebracht wurde dass selbst
ein Teil der
Regierungskoalitionen nämlich die FDP
das Gesetz gestoppt hat im Gegensatz zu
vielen anderen möchte ich Ihnen sagen
ich bin in der ausdrücklich dankbar
dafür dass die FDP das gemacht hat weil
so wie das Gesetz so wie das Gesetz
eingebracht wurde war es ein was
schlichtweg nicht umsetzbar aber jetzt
haben wir ein Problem die beraten jetzt
würde der sollen und die sage ich jetzt
ganz bewusst als Vorsitzende des
Ausschusses der Klimaschutz und Energie
wir sollen nächste Woche eine Anhörung
machen zu diesem Gesetz aber wir sollen
über dieses Gesetz selber eigentlich
reden sie reden ja auch nicht über das
Gesetz wir reden über einen Leitplanken
aber diese Leitplanken sind nicht das
Gesetz warum bitte geben Sie den
Parlament nicht genügend Zeit ein Gesetz
zu beraten wo drin steht was wirklich
passieren soll sondern warum sollen wir
nur über Leitplanken reden wo keiner
weiß wie sie das eigentlich im Gesetz
umsetzen soll das ist ein
parlamentisches parlamentarisches
Verfahren die sich so überhaupt nicht
akzeptiere und ich bin nicht voll bei
denen die sagen das geht so nicht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sollte eine Zwischenfrage oder zwischen
Bemerkung sein die jetzt aber nicht über
4 Minuten
aber man darf eigentlich machen jeden
der das Verfahren kritisiert im Prinzip
zu unterstellen da werden Klima Leugner
ich habe das in vielen Diskussionen
inzwischen rausgehört es geht darum ein
vernünftiges Gesetz zu machen dass die
Leute mitnehmen und dazu braucht man
ordentliches parlamentarisches Verfahren
kommen sie in sie gehen Sie in sich und
versuchen Sie dies zu gewährleisten zur
Zeit sehe ich dieses Verfahren nicht
vernünftig
lieber Herr Ernst danke für die
Zwischenfrage als Antwort darauf gibt es
glaube ich zwei Teile die ganz
wesentlich sind das erste ist doch sie
haben mit dem mit der zweiten Bemerkung
völlig rechts wir haben in diesem Land
gesehen was dieses Gesetz ausgelöst hat
wir haben in Debatten gesehen wie Freie
Wähler in reinen Populismus verfallen
weil sie von der AFD Stimmen abfangen
wollen wir haben gesehen wie dieses
gesamte Gesetz wie dieses gesamte Land
darüber diskutiert und Ring wie es ein
gutes Gesetz wird und das ist die
Aufgabe die wir in einem anderen
parlamentarischen Verfahren haben daraus
ein gutes Gesetz zu machen dazu wird in
einem Ausschuss diskutiert in die
Maschinenraum dieser Demokratie wird von
den Abgeordneten diskutiert und das
Gesetz verbessern und dazu wird auch
darüber diskutiert wie ein Gesetz
weiterentwickelt wird und dazu gibt es
einen ganz normales Verfahren indem wir
stecken und dass wir jetzt umsetzen
werden lieber Ernst ich frage mich wie
sie Demokratie und demokratische
Verfahren verstehen natürlich Ringen wir
jetzt darum und natürlich hat die
Diskussion in der Öffentlichkeit ein
ganz wesentlichen Anteil daran wie wir
dieses wir das jetzt besser machen und
natürlich hat die Debatte in diesem
Parlament ist ja nicht die erste Debatte
die wir über das Gebäude Energiegesetz
führt ein ganz wesentlichen Anteil der
Kern des Gesetzes musste verändert
werden der Kern des Gesetzes musste so
verändert werden dass wir sagen und ich
wiederhole es erst muss die Kommune
sagen was geht bei mir vor Ort und dann
muss der Bürger sich darauf abgestimmt
frei entscheiden können und das ist es
was sehr sehr klar auch aus dem
Leitplanken hervorgeht das ist aber auch
das was in der Bevölkerung jetzt schon
lange diskutiert wird und deswegen
glaube ich und da vertraue ich darauf
dass sie auch in der Linken diese Ideen
nachvollziehen können und das in einem
parlamentarischen Verfahren diskutieren
können das wird dann zu einem guten
Gesetzen vielen Dank
wir haben einen Verfahren und deswegen
würde ich hier an dieser Stelle auch
noch mal auf den Kollegen sparen
eingehen wollen
sie haben gesagt sie sind Verfahren
hätte es in den 16 Jahren Union nicht
gegeben und eigentlich bringe ich diese
16 Jahre gar nicht auf weil wir machen
Politik für die Zukunft für mich
interessiert wenig was die Union in der
Vergangenheit gemacht haben aber weil
sie das Thema angesprochen haben
ich kann mich an unterschiedliche
Gesetzgebungsverfahren in unserer
letzten oppositionsregierung
Oppositionszeit erinnern die ziemlich in
die Hose gehen aber ich möchte mal
darauf eingehen was die Idee der Union
war sie hätten dieses Gesetz von mir aus
auch in so einem Verfahren vor 16 Jahren
machen müssen sie hätten 2015 ein
Gebäude Energiegesetz vorlegen müssen
das dafür sorgt dass die Menschen wissen
wie es mit Ihrer Heizung weitergeht weil
das wäre dann genügend Zeit gewesen das
wären dann die 30 Jahre gewesen warum
diskutieren wir denn diese Themen weil
die Leute antworten brauchen darauf wie
Klimaschutz und Bezahlbarkeit
funktionieren soll weil die Leute
antworten darauf brauchen wie es
weitergehen soll und das haben sie nicht
gemacht was ist denn stattdessen die
Idee der Union gewesen in
ölheizungsverbot und das was jetzt von
alleine auf europäischer Ebene machten
Gasheizung sowohl ab 27 das ist die Idee
der Union das ist doch Wahnsinn stellen
sich nicht hin und sagen wir werden auch
europäischer Ebene dafür sorgen dass
unsere unsere
Kommissionspräsident dafür sorgt dass
dieser ganze Wahnsinn der EU-Ebene jetzt
da kommen soll nicht durchgesetzt wird
das wäre die Antwort gewesen die Leute
von ihnen erwarten das ist doch das
Trauerspiel sie haben keine eigenen
Antworten und deswegen sorge ich mich
darum wie sie als Opposition dieses
Gesetz begleiten werden wenn sie jetzt
sagen wir müssen dieses Gesetz weiter
diskutieren gut wenn sie sagen das hat
sich um 180 Grad gedreht das ist gut
dann geht das in die richtige Richtung
ich erwarte aber auch von Ihnen dass Sie
diese Debatte auf europäischer Ebene an
entsprechend klären das muss doch dazu
parallel gesagt werden wir müssen eine
geeignete Gesetzgebung haben die den
Menschen in Deutschland erklärt in
welche Richtung wir gehen das tun wir
mit den Leitplanken das werden wir mit
dem Gebäude Energiegesetz tun wir werden
ein gutes Gesetz machen und das ist die
Herausforderung Verantwortung die wir
haben die wir dann umsetzen und der wir
uns stellen vielen herzlichen Dank
vielleicht reden ja Koalition und
Oppositionen aneinander vor weil wenn
Herr Köder sagt der Kern des Gesetzes
musste verändert werden dann stellt sich
die Frage auf welcher Grundlage welcher
Textgrundlage sollen die Experten
kommenden Mittwoch hier im Bundestag
Stellungen nehmen Ralf Link hat jetzt
für die Linke Sprecher für Energie und
Klimaschutz
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich frage mich
wie schafft es die Ampel immer wieder
gute Ideen so vor die Wand zu fahren
dass sie keiner mehr hören will
wie schaffen Sie es Vertrauen komplett
zu zerstören wenn ich in einem Dorf in
meiner Heimat Thüringen das Wort
Heizungstausch in den Mund nehme dann
habe ich Glück wenn die Leute nur
wutreten halten und mich nicht
rauswerfen ich sage es klar der
Heizungstausch ist notwendig damit
Wohnungen langfristig warm bleiben wenn
Erdgas und Öl und bezahlbar werden aus
welchen Gründen auch immer sei es wegen
Krieg oder wegen Spekulation und auch
wegen dem Kampf gegen die Klima Probleme
und selbst die verkorkste ampelplanung
könnte man korrigieren aber wie sie
kommunizieren wie sie vertrauen
zerstören wie sie mit halbgarn Ideen
Akzeptanz vernichten und nochmal wie sie
kommunizieren und wie sie Angst auslösen
ist unterirdisch ist zum kotzen und der
Schaden den sie damit auslösen wird weit
über ihre Regierung hinaus würden
ich hoffe und wäre ich religiös werde
ich beten dass sie die wärmewende nicht
komplett an die Wand gefahren haben ich
sage es unmissverständlich sie haben die
Verantwortung umsetzbare Vorschläge zu
machen die die Gesellschaft auch leisten
kann und so zu kommunizieren dass die
Bevölkerung ist auch versteht das heute
eingebracht die Gesetz ist immer noch
der grottenschlechte erste Entwurf doch
statt Veränderung an den schädlichen
Paragraphen präsentiert die Ampel
Leitplanken
Leitplanken unverbindlich und teils zu
vage dass niemand weiß was
schlussendlich herauskommen wird
wenn verbindliche kommunale wärmeplanung
kommen das wäre gut
Wärmenetze ausbauen und Stärken auch als
Energiespeicher betrachten wäre eine
richtige Erkenntnis verpflichtende
Vorgaben erst bei vorhandenen kommunalen
wärmeplan damit nähern sie sich immerhin
realen Möglichkeiten
über 15 Millionen Heizungen müssen
umgestellt werden und da schlagen sie
vielleicht 1,5 Milliarden Förderung vor
da hätten sie die 1000 € pro
Heizungstausch bei den Kosten für
Eigentümer viel zu wenig das ist doch
absurd und woher sollen eigentlich die
Handwerker kommen
richtig krass schlimm wird es für
Mieterinnen und Mieter ihn droht eine
weitere Modernisierungsumlage auf die
horrenten Mietpreise oben drauf
unfassbar unerträglich
und die Ampel ignoriert was sie
anrichtet aber das machen sie mit ganzer
Kraft
liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger als
Techniker bin ich mir sicher dass die
Strom Wärme und Wasserstoff in
kraftstruktur auf die wärmewende
ausgebaut werden muss und das dann eine
soziale wärmewende möglich ist warm
mieten Neutralität garantieren und
modernisierungsumlagen abschaffen das
schafft notwendig Sicherheit für
Mieterinnen und Mieter
ausreichend Unterstützung von
Wohnungsunternehmen damit sie den Umbau
stemmen können unverletzt ohne
verzichtbar
Heizungstausch auch notwendig
begleitinvestitionen fördern eben auch
notwendige neue Heizkörper und sonstige
Sanierung und Fördermittel nach
Einkommen für Eigenheime und
Wohneigentum linear abnehmen aber mit
100% Förderung für
transferleistungsempfängerinnen 75%
Förderung für zwei Personen mit 70.000 €
im Jahr und für ein paar mit 300.000 €
und mehr da braucht es keine Förderung
Zins günstig KfW Kredite für den
Eigenanteil bereitstellen und Kommunen
mittels eines fördern und
bürgschaftsprogramm die Sanierung ihrer
Schulen und Gebäude ermöglichen damit
sie eben vorreiter sind
Koalition setzen Sie diese Vorschläge um
ansonsten bleibt das Gesetz was der
Entwurf ist Schrott vielen Dank
der Bundestag debattiert heute in erster
Lesung über das Gebäude in Energiegesetz
und der nächste Redner kommt von den
Bündnis Grünen
dann bitte ich wirklich alle noch mal im
Namen auf der Würde des Hauses
auch bei hitzigen Debatten vielleicht
das zu unterlassen das wäre auch für die
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer glaube ich
die kennen die aber das mag sein aber es
gucken auch junge Zuschauer vielleicht
da ich hoffe sehr dass auch junge
Menschen an Politik interessiert sind
für die Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
dran
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich verspreche Ihnen wieder kotzen noch
rotzen werde ich hier nicht aber auch
wenn wir uns gar keine Aufforderung aber
wenn wir uns bei diesen sommerlichen
Temperaturen gerade nicht vorstellen
können wir sind alle auf unsere Heizung
im Winter angewiesen wir alle ob wir es
wohnen oder arbeiten
bei der uns heute vorliegenden Novelle
des gebäudeenergiegesetzes handelt in
sich um ein unvermeidbares und
wirkungsvolles Gesetz für den
Klimaschutz und bei so einem Gesetz ist
es doch total logisch das ist nicht
seelenruhig durch
gesetzesverfahrenstechnischen
Gegebenheiten wandert sondern das dazu
schon lange eine knallharte
gesellschaftliche Auseinandersetzung
geführt wird und bei dem jetzt
greifenden Abschluss vor der Sommerpause
neigt sich diese Auseinandersetzung
endlich dem Ende zu und damit sorgen wir
für die nötige Planbarkeit und
Verlässlichkeit für Eigentümer
Handwerker in Schornsteinfeger oder
Energieberater und
uns
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen am Ende
für die Menschen da draußen der Weg bis
dahin war nicht einfach und als
Bauingenieur kann ich sagen unsere
Gebäude sind nicht einfach dieses Gesetz
betrifft die rund 21 Millionen
unterschiedlichen Gebäude in unserem
Land die Gebäude in den wir wohnen und
auch Arbeiten es betrifft Altbauten
genauso wie Neubauten ist betrifft
Einfamilienhäuser genauso wie
Krankenhäuser das kleine Dorf genauso
wie wie dicht bebaute in den Stadt
ungebäude in Ost und Westdeutschland
gleichermaßen der Osten steht dabei mit
mehr sanierten Gebäuden und den gut
ausgebauten Fernwärmenetzen der da
als Teil der kommunalen wärmeplanung
spielen wärmeetze künftig eine zentrale
Rolle sobald die wärmeplanung in eine
Kommune abgeschlossen ist können
Verbraucher aus dem Völlen schöpfen und
sich für die beste technologische Lösung
entscheiden mit unterschiedlichen
Optionen neben Wärmepumpen ist ab 2024
auch das Heizen mit Holz und Wasserstoff
möglich aber
hören sie zu aber hier ist Vorsicht
geboten es handelt sich bei Holz und
Wasserstoff um begrenzte und am Ende
auch teure Rohstoffe das gehört zu
Wahrheit deutlich dazu wer sich eine
neue Heizung einbaut muss das ab ehrlich
erfahren welche Kosten in beiden Betrieb
der Heizung entstehen wir Bündnis grüne
werden uns in den kommenden Wochen
deshalb auch unten Verbraucherschutz
bemühen durch eine sozial gestaffelte
Förderung mehr Mieterschutz und
Ausnahmeregelungen die für alle
nachvollziehbar sind meine Damen und
Herren und ich komme zum Schluss ich bin
optimistisch dass wir diesen Endspurt
gemeinsam für den Klimaschutz und am
Ende für den Bürgerinnen und Bürger in
diesem Lande hinbekommen vielen Dank
für die CDU hat jetzt ihr
stellvertretender Parteivorsitzende und
der Klima und Energie Experte der
Fraktion Andreas Jung das machen wollt
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Herr Minister Habig sie haben
vorher den Blick gerichtet auf das
Klimapaket 2019 sie haben die
Bundeskanzlerin zitiert mit dem Satz das
sei die Kunst des Möglichen sie haben
allerdings vergessen zu erwähnen was
damals ermöglicht wurde noch mehr haben
sie vergessen dass in dem Verfahren in
dem Vermittlungsverfahren zwischen Bund
und Ländern des damals gemacht wurde in
dem die Grünen nicht nur beteiligt waren
sind wo die Grünen am Ende zugestimmt
hat mit einer breiten politischen
Mehrheit Dinge möglich wurden die vorher
nicht möglich gewesen sind wir haben
damals die CO2 Bepreisung eingeführt
dieses marktwirtschaftliche Instrumente
des Klimaschutzes von dem ist klare
Signal ausgeht wer bei Öl und Gas bleibt
der muss damit rechnen bei einem
moderaten Einstieg es wird niemand
überfordert er muss damit rechnen das
Stück verstecken wird aber so dass
marktwirtschaftliche Lösungen ermöglicht
werden das haben wir gemeinsam mit in
einem vereinbarten Pfad eingeführt und
mit dem Blick auf Europa sehr deutlich
das ist unser Weg in Europa und wir
haben es durchgesetzt wo waren sie da wo
waren die Bundesregierung als wir dafür
gekämpft haben dass ein Durchbruch
gegeben hat in Brüssel für dieses
marktwirtschaftliche Instrument der
CO2-Preise das haben wir im Dezember
erreicht und das muss es leicht
Instrument in Brüssel bleiben nicht
zwangsanierung nicht Vorgaben für den
Heizung
marktwirtschaftliche Instrumenten die
CO2 für Preise aber wir haben es damit
verbunden deswegen es muss ein sozialen
Ausgleich geben es muss Unterstützung
geben es ist eingeführt worden die
Steuerförderung für die Gebäudesanierung
Heizung und Hülle zusammen denken anders
als sie es machen wo sie nur an die
Heizung und Höhle gehören zusammen es
braucht ein gemeinsames Konzept wir
haben diese Steuerförderung eingeführt
und sie wirkt kann man an den Zahlen
ablesen die Pflichten in den Raum
gestellt haben die kommen sollen da
haben die Leute wieder auf die fossilen
Gesetze sie macht das ist das
Konjunkturprogramm für die fossilen es
gibt einen Rahmen auf Öl und Gasheizung
sie erreichen mit denen mit der Abkehr
des Grundsatzes fördern und fordern das
war unser Grundsatz ihr Grundsatz in
diesem Gesetz ist jetzt vom Baum
gefallen ist das überreife Pflaume ihr
Grundsatz ist verbieten verhindern und
das ist die Abkehr und das führt zu
dieser Verunsicherung und deshalb
drängen wir darauf und wir haben Sie
unseren Vorschläge immer wieder
eingebracht dass man ja beschleunigen
das wird technologieoffen ist dass man
aber auch sozialverträglich ist und
immer damit mitdenkt wie nehmen wir bei
dieser menschheitsaufgabe Johannesburg
nehmen wir bei dieser Menschheit Aufgabe
Klimaschutz die Menschen somit ist die
Akzeptanz erhalten bleibt
und es ist die
große Leerstelle in dem man sie
Leitplanken nennen sie eine bessere
Pressemitteilung sie große Lehrstelle
sie haben die Förderung die wir
eingeführt haben am Beispiel der
Wärmepumpe mit 50% bekommen ihre
Regierung hat die Förderung gekürzt
40%. dann haben Sie mit Frau Geiwitz
gemeinsam ein Vorschlag gemacht neue
Förderung 30 %. Sonderfälle können mehr
bekommen aber für die Mitte der
Gesellschaft die hier angesprochen wird
30 %. und in diesem Konzept gibt kein
Wort drin wie die Förderung ausgestaltet
werden soll ihr Konzept ist bei allen
Koalitionsfraktionen durchgefallen jeder
hat seine eigene Vorstellung die Grünen
wollen bis zu 80% der FDP ist irgendwie
dagegen von der SPD weiß man es nicht es
gibt keine Klarheit auf die Frage die
Menschen im Land umteilt was kommt auf
mich zu was wird Kosten und welche
finanzielle Förderung gibt es dazu sie
haben jetzt die erste Lesung darauf
keine Antwort und dann wundern sie sich
dass die Verunsicherung weitergeht
und Gesamtkonzept und
technologieoffenheit die Worte hören wir
wohl wir wollen jetzt aber Taten sehen
wenn sie haben doch bisher auch schon
gesagt seit technologieoffen haben sie
in jeder ihrer Rede gesagt nur wenn wir
in ihr Gesetz reingeguckt hätte dann
wird technologieoffenheit
etikettenschwinden dann wurde Heizen mit
Holz diskriminiert deshalb ist unsere
Frage wenn da jetzt drin steht heizt mit
Holz zu gehen aber viel Anreize sie
sollen vermieden werden was ist denn
damit gemeint dieser Strauß an Vorgaben
der bisher drin steht lauter Auflagen
die im Ergebnis dazu führen das heißt
mit Holz im nicht geht ist keine Option
ist denn auf dem doch wieder auf die
Wärmepumpe ausläuft bekennen sie sich in
ihrem Leben dazu Heizen mit Holz wird
gleichberechtigt akzeptiert als eine
Option als eine Alternative gleiches
Recht für alle öko-heizung das wollen
wir und das haben wir bisher in ihrem
Konzepten nicht erkennen können und auch
bei der Ferne
auch bei der Fernwärme auch bei der
Fernwärme wollen sie doch erneuerbare
Energien nicht in der ganzen Breite
ermöglichen sie wollen Biomasse Deckel
und sie wollen den Anteil der Biomasse
nicht ausbauen ihr Ziel steht ja in dem
Gesetzentwürfen drin ihr Ziel ist den
Anteil der Biomasse Stück für Stück
zurückzufahren das ist genau der falsche
Weg im nicht diese Einseitigkeit die
ganze Breite auch die Bioenergie ist
eine wichtige Form für nachhaltige
Energieerzeugung und diese
Bundesregierung diskriminiert und
fortlaufen die Bioenergie deshalb wollen
wir jetzt hier die Gesetze sehen und
dann werden wir es prüfen wir fahren
technologieoffen als
Sozialverträglichkeit nur so wird die
wärmewende zum erfolgen das ist unser
Ziel herzlichen Dank
für die SPD kommt als nächster der
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzenden
Matthias
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen als jemand der jetzt 17 Jahre
Klimapolitik im Deutschen Bundestag
macht
habe ich sehr aufmerksam diese Debatte
bislang verfolgt
und mir wird klar
was passieren kann wenn wir nicht alle
als DemokratInnen und Demokraten sehr
sorgfältig mit dieser Debatte umgehen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist
völlig legitim dass wir hier über
Gesetze über Inhalte diskutieren aber
Herr Kollege freie und Herr Kollege
Spahn sie müssen schon aufpassen dass
wenn Sie hier an die Grundfeste
demokratischer Strukturen diese in Frage
stellen über Vorgehen ob dieses ob diese
Kritik eigentlich bei ihnen einzahlt
oder Wasser auf die Mühlen dieser
Populisten sind die dieses Land kaputt
machen wollen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und ich bin ausgesprochen dankbar lieber
an die jungen leider was du mit deiner
Klimapolitik in den letzten Jahren nie
symbolstiften für die Politik der CDU
aber wir sind jetzt in dieser Ampel in
der Lage und ich bin ausgesprochen
dankbar den Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
FDP und der Grünen dass wir hier eine
Herkulesaufgabe stimmen dass wir uns das
vorgenommen haben und wir werden das
schaffen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
denn jetzt wird Klimaschutz konkret
jetzt geht es um die Dinge die jede und
jede unmittelbar spüren werden es geht
eben um Heizungssysteme es geht um
Mobilität der Zukunft abstrakt sind alle
immer für Klimaschutz aber wenn es
konkret wird sind die gesellschaftlichen
Herausforderungen mannigfach und das
erleben wir hier und heute liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und deswegen werden wir dieses nur
stemmen können und das ist der
sozialdemokratische Ansatz in den
letzten Jahren immer gewesen wenn wir
die ökologische Frage mit der sozialen
und der wirtschaftlichen verbinden wir
können es nicht einseitig lösen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und deswegen
bin ich dankbar dass das was wir
erarbeitet haben ja in Müser seligen
Diskussionen dass diese Arbeit jetzt
heute und gestern von denen gewürdigt
wird auf dieses ankommt zum Beispiel auf
die kommunalen Spitzenverbände vielen
Dank dass dieser Weg jetzt konstruktiv
von dieser Ebene begleitet wird das
finde ich muss man hier betonen
und lieber an die jungen wenn du die
Bepreisung in den Mittelpunkt stellst
dann sage ich es noch einmal das sind
fundamentale grundsätzlich
unterschiedliche Ansätze die wir haben
und ich habe in der letzten Woche darauf
hingewiesen und der Kollege Merz ich
habe es im Protokoll noch mal
nachgelesen als ich gesagt habe was
heißt eigentlich Bepreisung wie wir sie
beschlossen haben wenn wir es nicht
flankieren es führt dazu dass Leute
schlichtweg sich nicht mehr leisten
können dann zu heizen und Mobilität da
sagen sie da haben sie zwischengerufen
Herr Kollege Merz wie kommen Sie darauf
ich lade sie wirklich ein zu einem
Gespräch mal wo wir uns den Bepreisung
und emotionsfahrt angucken er führt dazu
dass sie soziale Ungleichheit bekommen
und manifestieren in lebenswichtigen
Elementen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
das ist nicht unser Weg
und deswegen ist es richtig gerade die
in den Mittelpunkt der Planung zu
stellen auf die es ankommen wird ganz
nach dem Motto der Vereinten Nationen
global denken lokal handeln die Kommunen
werden vor Ort regionale Unterschiede
berücksichtigen können und auf die Wege
setzen die möglich sind wenn es um
zukünftige Wärmeversorgung geht das geht
von Wärmepumpen das geht über Geothermie
es wird über Fernwärme geben die
Möglichkeiten sind mannigfach und diese
Möglichkeiten bis einschließlich auch
Holz und Pellets werden wir ermöglichen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ja und es ist richtig es ist noch nicht
geklärt und wir werden das in den
nächsten drei Wochen klären müssen wir
haben die Mieterinnen und Mieter in den
Blick zu nehmen aber wir haben natürlich
auch die Vermieter in den Blick zu
nehmen weil es bringt nichts wenn die
Modernisierung nicht erreicht wird im
Gebäude bestanden und insofern sind das
eben auch Interessenskonflikte die wir
hier lösen müssen wenn wir politische
Verantwortung übernehmen wir wollen dass
wir niemand überfordert wird deswegen
stehen die Mieterinnen und Mieter bei
uns auch in Zentrum
und am Ende und das muss man auch sagen
geht es nur wenn dieser Staat wenn diese
Gemeinschaft die Menschen unterstützt
auf diesem Weg deswegen wird es um
Förderung gehen und natürlich ist es
auch hier so das darf man überhaupt
nicht verschweigen das zwischen FDP
zwischen Grünen und SPD ein
unterschiedlicher Ansatz besteht wenn es
um Finanzierung des Staates und dieser
Maßnahmen geht aber ich bin sicher auch
nach den letzten Tagen wir werden das
Stemmen und wir werden hier eine Lösung
anbieten ich freue mich auf den
parlamentarischen Beratung vielen Dank
für Ihre
nächster Redner für die afd-fraktion
Carsten Hilse
[Applaus]
wer das Präsidium meine Damen und Herren
liebe Landsleute wieder und wieder und
wieder werden von der Ampel getrieben
von der grünen klimasektor verheerende
Gesetzentwürfe vorgelegt und gegen jede
Vernunft unter Missachtung sämtlicher
Regeln dieses Hohen Hauses
durchgepeitscht hauptsache es dient der
klimaideologie der Grünen Kommunisten
eingesetzt dass alle Haushalte alle
Firmen alle Vermieter alle Mieter alle
Eigenheimbesitzer alle Kommunen also
wirklich praktisch alle betrifft sie
sollen geht es nach dem Willen der
Grünen aller Parteien gezwungen werden
bis 2045 klimaneutral zu heizen mit den
Erfahrungen aus der corona-dikator macht
man sich daran alle Bürger und ein
klimajoch zu pressen Vorderschaft gülner
veranlasst die zur Aussage Zitat frühere
SPD Wähler haben den Eindruck dass sich
ihre Partei eine Art grüner Diktatur
beugt und konkretisiert wenn eine kleine
elitäre Minderheit der Gesellschaft der
großen Mehrheit der anders denkt in ihre
Werte durch Belehrungen und Verbote
aufzwingen kann das wohl als eine Art
Diktatur gewertet werden recht hat der
Zitat Ende und dieser Zwang diese
Verbote betreffen natürlich alle uns
alle entsprechend groß sind der
Aufschreiben der Widerstand und die
nachvollziehbare Wut diese Wut nehmen
die Macher natürlich war und trotzdem
bringen sie das Gesetz heute ein faseln
in ihrem hochdrand Leitplanken für das
Gebäude
Gebäude Energiegesetz genannten Pamphlet
von einem breiten Konsens der
Gesellschaft des Deutschland bis 2045
klimaneutral sein soll der behauptete
Konsens ist aber eine glatte Lüge Klima
Neutralität geht laut einer Spiegel und
Frage von 30 März inzwischen der Hälfte
Deutschland war am Allerwertesten vorbei
80% der Menschen im Land lehnen ihren
sogenannten Heizkammer ab und gegen
diese 80 Prozent machen Sie Ihre
verheerende Politik doch das wirklich
Schlimme ist dass die anderen
Altparteien Ihnen dazu auch noch die
Hand reichen von den spezialdemokraten
und den Grünen Kommunisten erwartet man
dazwischen nichts anderes mehr das aber
die Feigen Demokraten dabei mitspielen
ist der ist die eigentliche trage
trotzdem mini-änderungen für die sich
die Feigen Demokraten feiern ist und
bleibt es ein verheerendes Gesetz
Wohlstand und Arbeitsplätze vernichtend
wie es sonst nur ein Krieg vermag manche
Volk bezeichnen ihre Politik inzwischen
als einen Krieg gegen das eigene Volk
und jeder der sich an diesem Krieg
beteiligt wird sich der eines vor diesem
Volk Verantwortung müssen die einzige
Partei die sich gegen diesen kollektiven
Suizid stemmt ist die AFD
vollgerechtigt steigen folgerichtig
steigen unsere Stimmung Zustimmungswerte
das ist gut für Deutschland schlecht für
Deutschland ist dass mit jedem Tag den
diese Regierung ihr Vernichtungswerk
weiter betreibt der Trümmerhaufen immer
größer wird den wir als zukünftige
Regierungspartei wegzuräumen haben
aber wir werden es tun verlassen sich
darauf und im Übrigen bin ich der
Meinung der Grünen wählt wird den Krieg
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
nächste Redner für die Rednerin für die
FDP-Fraktion Karina Konrad sie ist eine
der stellvertretenden
Fraktionsvorsitzenden in der
FDP-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen hier wurde
mehrfach von der Opposition gefordert
sie wollen ein gutes Gesetz das haben
wir Freie Demokraten auch gefordert wir
wollen ein vernünftiges Gesetz sie
wollen ein fachlich ordentliches Gesetz
und meine Damen und Herren genau daran
arbeiten wir jetzt das ist ein
ordentliches Gesetz wird ein fachlich
vernünftiges Gesetz und ein gutes Gesetz
das bekommen sie wir setzen dieses
Gesetz jetzt vom Kopf auf die Füße da wo
es hingehört
und Herr frei und Herr Spahn man kann
Verfahren kritisieren und man kann die
Kritik am Verfahren als Opposition in
den Mittelpunkt der Debatte stellen
die ich in
den letzten erlebt habe die
interessieren sich nicht dafür wie die
Opposition dazu in der Lage ist mit
Verfahren umzugehen die erwarten zu
Recht dass wir diese Probleme lösen die
kommunikativ und auch durch Dinge
entstanden sind die wir nicht mehr
rückgängig machen müssen können und
diese Probleme lösen wir jetzt
und
die Bürger erwarten zu Recht eingesetzt
das ökologisch ist das ökonomisch
machbar ist das sozial ausgewogen ist
und das vor allen Dingen diese
Anforderungen jetzt auch in einen Bus
bringt und diese schwierigen
abwägungsfragen miteinander auswegt und
wenn es um den Klimaschutz geht ist das
kein Thema was man einfach von der Hand
wischen kann ich bin Landwirtinnen und
erlebe seit Jahren was für konkrete
finanzielle Auswirkungen der Klimaschutz
hat wenn wir ihn nicht betreiben auf dem
Acker deshalb müssen wir das machen und
deshalb tun wir das in dem
heizungsgesetz so dass keine
Diskriminierung zwischen Heizungsarten
stattfindet die man alle verwenden kann
in Zukunft es wird keine Diskriminierung
geben
und der nachhaltige Umgang und den
nachhaltige Bewirtschaftung von Wald ist
selbstverständlich im Mittelpunkt auf
unserer Debatte gewesen deshalb werden
Holz und Pellets auch weiterhin nutzbar
sein und sie haben gefragt was bedeutet
das denn Fehlanreize zu vermeiden das
bedeutet dass wir nicht wollen was sie
glaube ich auch nicht wollen Liebe Union
das in
massenholzimporte aus dem Ausland zu uns
kommen weil wir falsche Anreize setzen
das wollen wir nicht aber wir wollen
dass unser Holz vernünftig weiter
verheizt werden kann so wie es schon
seit Jahrzehnten und Jahrhunderten getan
wird und das ist auch richtig so Frau
Konrad gestatten sie eine Zwischenfrage
oder zwischen Bemerkung aus der cdu/c zu
Fraktion vom Kollegen danke nein wir
machen ein Gesetz das auch physikalisch
machbar ist
und physikalisch machbar machen wir
dieses Gesetz dadurch dass wir es ganz
eng mit der kommunalen wärmeplanung
verzahnen werden das bedeutet dass wir
Zeit Horizonte Kriegen in denen die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger sich auch darauf
einstellen können und mit der Materie
auseinandersetzen können und das
bedeutet auch ein Gesetz wirtschaftlich
vernünftig zu machen und dafür wird es
natürlich Förderungen geben und dafür
wird es natürlich auch die die
Unterstützung geben für diejenigen die
auch bis in die Mitte in unserer
Gesellschaft hinein nicht dazu in der
Lage sind einfach mal so eine neue
Heizung zu kaufen weil das auch eine
Investition ist und deshalb
wird die Modernisierungsumlage weil es
angesprochen wurde auch bei 8% bleiben
aber wir haben uns Gedanken gemacht wie
man das auflösen kann und das werden wir
im weiteren Verfahren kritisieren wie
man auch Vermieter dazu bringt
Investitionen in Heizungen zu tätigen
dabei eine Förderung und Anspruch zu
nehmen weil das natürlich nachher die
gesamtumlage auf die Mieter senkt und
das wollen wir erreichen und das werden
wir durch diese weitere
Modernisierungsumlage erreichen wenn wir
sie vernünftig ausgestalten und darüber
diskutieren werden
und meine Damen und Herren es gab viel
Kritik an diesem Verfahren in den
letzten Wochen auch von uns Freien
Demokraten und deshalb haben wir uns
unserer demokratischen Aufgabe gestellt
und Lösungen gesucht und ich danke auch
den Koalitionspartnern für die
intensiven Gespräche die wir in den
letzten Wochen miteinander geführt haben
und ich freue mich dass es viel Lob gab
von vielen Verbänden die ausdrücklich in
dieser Woche es auch anerkannt haben
dass wir diese Leistung vollbracht haben
ich glaube das ist ein ganz ganz
wichtiger Weg um dieses Gesetz jetzt
auch in den nächsten Wochen im
parlamentarischen Verfahren zu einem
sehr guten Gesetz zu machen zu einem
vernünftigen Gesetz zu machen und zu
einem Gesetz das fachlich so ordentlich
ist dass es die Menschen mit überlastet
und ihr Eigentum schützt und dass die
Schornsteinfeger ihr Lob an unseren
Leitplanken geäußert haben das hat mich
ganz besonders gefreut gefreut das
bringt vielleicht auch ein bisschen
Glück für die zukünftigen Beratungen
auch mit der Opposition gerade mit der
CDU das würde mich freuen
bevor ich den nächsten reden Aufrufe hat
das Wort zu einer Kurzintervention der
Kollege heim
Thomas Heilmann von der CDU
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin dass sie
die Kurzintervention zulassen Frau
Kollegin Konrad ich wollte Sie fragen
weil sie ja gesagt haben dass die Bürger
würden sich nicht für Verfahrensfragen
interessieren das wenn sie da
geschäftsordnungsfragen hier fragen
würde ich ihnen zustimmen aber die Frage
die ich ihnen stellen wollte wann dürfen
wir damit rechnen dass aus den
Leitplanken ein Gesetzestext werden über
den wir hier ordnungsgemäß beraten
konkret gefragt wird es zu der geplanten
Anhörung in der nächsten Sitzungswoche
am Mittwoch
einen neuen
Entwurf geben
zweite Frage wie viel
seitenänderungsanträge erwarten dürfen
wir den erwarten werden es mehr oder
weniger als 100 Seiten werden
und wie viel Tage halten sie im minimal
notwendig diese Änderungsanträge in
dieser Seitenzahl die ich in dieser
Größenordnung erwarte wie viel Tage
glauben sie ist notwendig um die
ordentlich zu lesen ordentlich darüber
nachzudenken gegebenenfalls Anmerkungen
wäre zu machen um sie dann abschließend
im Ausschuss ja in der übernächsten
Sitzungswoche Mittwoch geplant
behandeln und dann am vermutlich am
Donnerstag in 2 und 3 Lesung zu beraten
sie dürfen Antworten
sehr geehrter Herr Heilmann vielen Dank
für die Frage ich bin jetzt auch froh
dass ich sie nicht zugelassen hatte eben
in meiner Rede weil ich Ihnen die
schlichtweg nicht beantworten kann weil
ich nicht im
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium die
Zuständigkeit habe und auch nicht im
Bundesbauministerium die Zuständigkeit
hat dafür Vorlagen zu schreiben wir
werden uns bemühen und das sage ich
ihnen zu machen sie mal ernst seien sie
mal ein bisschen Ernst bei dieser
Debatte ich sage Ihnen für meine
Fraktion dass wir
dass sie auch ordentlich als Opposition
einzubinden und ich sage Ihnen auch zu
dass wir alles dafür tun werden dieses
Gesetz jetzt schnell in einen
vernünftigen Prozess und ein vernünftige
Beratungsgegenstand überzuführen dafür
diskutieren wir im Zweifel auch Tag und
Nacht
ja es wäre sicherlich ratsam eingesetzt
Text zu haben den man dann hier am
Schluss im Deutschen Bundestag und einem
Bundesrat verabschiede nächster Redner
Bernhard
Hermann von dem bündnisgrün ist mit dem
Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und Energie
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
Wort vernünftig Frau Kolleginnen Konrad
im Zusammenhang mit Holz ich denke wir
werden darüber reden weil ob es
vernünftig ist bei starken Sonnenschein
den ganzen Sommer durch große Kessel mit
Holzverbrennung laufen zu lassen das
darf man diskutieren das werden wir tun
sehr verantwortlich und genauso auch wie
wichtig Emissionsschutz gerade auch bei
der Holzverbrennung ist
für den Klimaschutz die sozialgerechte
Energieversorgung Klarheit für alle
Beteiligten ist es ein wichtiger Schritt
dass wir das heizungsgesetz nun endlich
im Bundestag debattieren das Gesetz ist
ein wichtiger Schritt hin zum
klimaneutralen heizen bis 2045 aber es
ist unabdingbar dass wir möglichst
schnell damit auch die Emissionen
reduzieren dabei kann uns dieses Gesetz
helfen manche scheint zu vergessen dass
die Klimaziele auf die das Gebäude
Energiegesetz abzielt schon von der
letzten Regierung beschlossen wurden mit
der Novellierung wollen wir diese Ziele
sozial gerecht erreichen dafür braucht
es Ordnungsrecht und Förderprogramme
alternativ bräuchte man einen CO2-Preis
diese CDU CSU haben sie zu von 200 bis
300 € pro Tonne Herrn Spahn scheint es
nicht zu interessieren das würde gerade
Entschuldigung gestatten sie eine
Zwischenfrage oder Bemerkung aus der
afd-fraktion gesichert nein das würde
gerade die Einkommen schwachen Haushalte
überlasten
wichtiger Punkt 200 bis 300 Euro pro
Tonne überlastet die einkommensschwachen
Haushalte Herren scheint das nicht zu
interessieren unsere Förderprogramme
hingegen werden vor allem die Haushalte
unterstützen die sich eine Umstellung
auf klimadeutrales heizen sonst nicht
allein leisten könnten im letzten Jahr
haben wir alle mit erschreckend zusehen
müssen wie die bisher immer billigen
Gaspreise gerade zu explodierten Heizen
mit Gas ist noch immer teuer wird wieder
teurer werden und nie kalkulierbar
seinen Strompreise sind wieder vor
krisen-niveau gucken sie hin wir haben
offenbar keine Ahnung die Kosten für
fossiles Gas steigen durch den hohen
CO2-Preis immer stärker aber auch mit
Wasserstoff wäre die Gasheizung
kostspielig denn dieser ist als ein
Heizstoff in einzelheizung ineffizient
und folglich
physikalisch bedingt sehr teuer
Wasserstoff grüne Gase werden sehr teuer
bleiben
die klimafreundlicheren und langfristig
günstigeren Alternativen sind wärmeetze
und hocheffiziente Wärmepumpen
effiziente Lösungen stärken wir mit dem
Gesetz auch nach dem Beschluss des
Gesetzes bleibt viel zu tun die
kommunalen wärmepläne müssen erstellt
und Heizsysteme in vielen Gebäuden
umgestellt werden auch politisch
nachzusteuern wird sein um die Umsetzung
zu optimieren ganz normal für solch ein
grundsätzlichen Transformationsprozess
wir sehen Waldbrände und Dürren
inzwischen auch an vielen Orten in
Deutschland
wir haben klar definierte Klimaziele
also gilt es die Emission im
Gebäudesektor in den nächsten acht
Jahren und 40 Prozent zu senken und
innerhalb der kommenden 22 Jahre den
Gebäudebestand klimaneutral zu gestalten
die Aufgabe fordert uns alle jede und
jeden auch uns als Gesellschaft
insgesamt niemand hat sich bisher diese
Herausforderung Jenseits plakativer
Sonntagsreden ehrlich gestellt wir aber
gehen diesen wichtigen Schritt es müssen
aber noch viele weitere folgen faire
langfristig bezahlbare Wärme sozial
gerecht mit einem hohen Maß an Mieter
und Verbraucherschutz das ist unser Ziel
vielen Dank
bevor ich den nächsten Redner Aufrufe
hat das Wort zu einer Kurzintervention
versichert Martin sicher von der AFD
vielen Dank
Herr Kollege
Herr Kollege wir haben hier jetzt von
ihnen ein Gesetz
vorliegen womit sie die Gasheizungen in
Deutschland verbieten wollen sie haben
jetzt an den eingangs ihre Rede auch
noch gesagt Sie wollen das die Heizung
mit Holz wollen sie nicht haben sie
wollen das alles nicht haben und wir
sehen zugleich dass China jede Woche
zwei große Kohlekraftwerke ans Netz
setzt in China sind mehr Kohlekraftwerke
in Planung und in Bau als in ganz
Deutschland überhaupt laufen wir haben
hier ein Projekt was die Bürger massiv
belastet was die Steuerzahler massiv
belastet weil sie wollen ja jetzt wieder
alles mögliche hier subventionieren wir
sehen auf der anderen Seite aber dass
wir damit hier einen gewissen Alleingang
haben weil überall auf der Welt gilt das
Primat das bei der Energieversorgung
gelten muss die Energie muss günstig und
bezahlbar sein für alle Menschen und
deswegen bauen viele Länder auf der Welt
Atomkraftwerke viele Länder auf der Welt
Kohlekraftwerke und setzen darauf dass
die Energieversorgung für uns ihre
Bevölkerung günstig ist nur hier in
Deutschland machen wir den totalen
Wahnsinn indem wir sagen wir gehen aus
den ganzen günstigen Energieformen raus
wir wollen jetzt hier alles staatlich
subventioniert haben und wollen hier
eine Energieversorgung die die Menschen
in vielen Bereichen nicht bezahlen
können und die für sie massiv belastbar
sind wie passt das zusammen dass wir
hier in Deutschland die bürgergängen
dass wir immer mehr verbote bringen
während in China jede Woche zwei große
Kohlekraftwerke ans Netz gehen
Herr Hermann möchten Sie antworten
[Applaus]
sehr gerne kann ich dort Antworten
offenbar geht den Fossil Lobbyisten der
AFD mächtig die Düse denn die Welt ist
eine ganz andere es ist schön dass sie
mir mal erlauben damit ein paar Fakten
wirklich gerade zurück und klar zu
stellen
zunächst ist es so dass das Gesetz auch
in seiner bisherigen Entwurfsfassung das
Heizen mit Holz komplett im Bestand
erlaubt es vernünftig flankiert mit
Emissionsanforderungen und der
Aufforderung eben bei Sonnenschein nicht
unbedingt einen großen Holzheizkessel
laufen zu lassen alles andere ist nicht
wahr
und bei Neubau darf man durchaus
unterschiedliche Auffassung sein bei
hocheffizienten Gebäuden
Photovoltaik in China oder
Kohlekraftwerke in China in Deutschland
haben wir es im letzten Jahr geschafft
wieder endlich 7 GB Photovoltaik
zuzubauen nachdem es lange Zeit gut ein
Gigawatt nur noch war die CDU komplett
die Photovoltaik zusammen mit den ganz
rechten gebremst hat jetzt sind es
wieder sieben Gigawatt und jetzt hören
Sie zu wenn sie was lernen wollen wenn
Sie Interesse haben und nicht Grinsen
und verhöhnen Herr Hilse 87 Gigawatt
sind in China letztes Jahr gebaut worden
sieben zu 87 in China Photovoltaik schön
das ruhig ist können Sie weiter zu in
diesem Jahr die ersten vier Monate sind
in China 48 GB bereits gebaut worden
eine Herausforderung für uns und sie
sorgen dafür dass wir technologisch beim
Klimaschutz bei aller
Fortschrittlichkeit abgehängt werden sie
bremsen und Verunsicherung dieses Land
und ich Chinesen machen das nicht weil
es
die Chinesen machen das nicht weil es
teuer ist sondern weiß die
wirtschaftlichere Form ist und genau
deswegen machen wir das auch und wenn
sie auch mal mit den Industrien Handels
kann man bei ihnen in der Region
unterwegs werden ich habe das noch nicht
gehört und mit den Unternehmen reden
würden die brauchen Herr Hilse auch
übrigens in Sachsen Windstrom damit die
Energie vor Ort bezahlbar bleibt wir
kriegen einen Weg dank der Industrie das
wissen sie nicht weil sie mit der
Industrie nicht sprechen
zum Thema Atomkraft zum Thema
Atomkraftwerke wir haben viele Themen
angesprochen erlauben sie es mir dass
ich kurz darauf eingehe es gibt im
marktwirtschaftlichen System in Europa
ganze drei AKW Neubauten alle desastros
teuer nie marktwirtschaftlich abdeckbar
und auch die FDP hat lange Zeit ja
gesagt Lösung die nicht versicherbar
sind kann man marktwirtschaftlich nicht
durchsetzen zum Thema Braunkohle könnte
ich ähnliches ausführlich sparen mir das
schon danke
nächster Redner in der Debatte für die
cdu/csu-fraktion DR Andreas Lenz
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wenn man es
schaffen will die Menschen im Land
maximal aber auch wirklich maximal zu
verunsichern dann muss man es genauso
machen wie die Ampel beim heizungsgesetz
das muss man der Ampel lassen das hat
sie nachhaltig geschafft sie sind
verantwortlich für eine riesen
Verunsicherung die bis tief in die Mitte
der Gesellschaft reicht meine Damen und
Herren und Ursache ursache ist ein von
Beginn ein vermurkstes Gesetz und nichts
anderes meine Damen und Herren
es gab und gibt Petitionen es gab
Demonstrationen bei denen Menschen
teilnahmen die noch nie vorher in ihrem
Leben demonstriert haben beispielsweise
auch in meinem Wahlkreis in der Stadt
Erding 13.000 Menschen und das waren
nicht das war nicht lauter
rechtsradikale das waren zum ganz
überwiegenden Teil bis auf einige Störer
normale Menschen das waren Handwerker
das waren Landwirte
Verwaltungsangestellte Ärzte Arbeiter
alles Menschen die von ihnen
verunsichert sind von ihren Plänen die
einfach Angst haben finanziell
überfordert zu werden Menschen die eben
keine grüne bevormundungs- und
Verbotspolitik wollen meine Damen und
Herren
Herr Dr Lenz Herr Dr Lenz
[Applaus]
alle mal wieder ein bisschen ruhig Herr
Dr Lenz eine Frage gestatten Sie eine
Frage oder zwischen Bemerkung aus der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 gegründe ja Frau
Kollegin sie haben das Wort
lieber Kollege Lenz vielen Dank dass Sie
die Zwischenfrage zulassen sie sprechen
die Demo in Erding selbst an nicht alle
verfolgen ja Tag und Nacht was in Bayern
los ist aber sie sind ja von der CSU sie
haben es offensichtlich genau verfolgt
und ich würde sie jetzt gerne noch mal
fragen wie sie zu dieser sogenannten
heiz-demo stehen sie haben eigentlich
klargemacht dass sie dahinter stehen
eine Demonstration wo Menschen mit
Morddrohung gegen demokratische Parteien
standen
die massiv aufgewertet wurde durch einen
Besuch des bayerischen
Ministerpräsidenten und wo ein
stellvertretender Ministerpräsident
erklärt hat er wolle sich die Demokratie
zurückholen übrigens die Demokratie die
ihn als stellvertreten Ministerpräsident
in seinem Land legitimiert hat und das
schlimme ist wir haben keine Demenz
gehört von Herrn awanger und von der
gesamten Staatsregierung nicht und wir
sehen jetzt an ihrer Haltung heute dass
sie anscheinend entschlossen sind diese
heizungsdebatte Debatte über Heizungen
in unserem Land eine technische Debatte
weiter zu nutzen um den populistinnen
Menschen zuzutreiben und unsere
Demokratie anzuzünden wollen Sie diese
Debatte dazu nutzen oder
oder werden sich hier und heute davon
distanzieren
[Applaus]
danke für diese Frage es war die Ampel
und keine kein anderer der diese
Verunsicherung bis tief in die Mitte
unserer Gesellschaft verursacht hat es
waren vieles bei ihre Schuld die
Menschen hatten wegen ihren Plänen die
Sie jetzt vielleicht wieder
ankünstlichen Abend zumal nämlich und
ich kann Ihnen sagen wenn sie normaler
Menschen nicht ernst nehmen Lenz hat das
Wort dann wird ihre Politik scheitern
ich war vor Ort ich habe mir das
angeschaut und es war nicht so dass es
ein rechter Mord war natürlich bei einer
bei einer Demonstration von 13 000
Menschen da sind natürlich auch Idioten
dabei das ist auch ein Sammelbecken eine
sind auch unbelehrbare dabei aber nicht
die Masse der oder die Angst haben
und
ich verbitte mir ich verbitte mir dass
sie jeden der gegen dieses Gesetz
demonstriert hat hat in eine
generalhaftung oder in eine Geiselhaft
nehmen
Menschen Menschen hatten und haben Angst
wegen ihren Plänen machen sie anständige
ordentliche Politik dann wird es auch
keine Demonstrationen geben herzlichen
Dank
[Applaus]
und übrigens war es auch so dass sich
der bayerische ministerpräsidenz ganz
klar von der AFD aber auch von anderen
Verschwörungstheorien abgegrenzt hat bei
dieser Demo das war so das können Sie
auch entsprechend nachhören und allein
allein ihre
allein ihre heizungspläne zum Holz zum
Holz haben zu einer großen
Verunsicherung geführt es muss man doch
sagen man muss doch erstmal drauf kommen
Holzheizungen im Neubau zu verbieten das
ist doch völlig egal das ist doch das
ist doch ein schlechter Witz meine Damen
und Herren
und es ist natürlich gut dass dagegen
auch gekämpft wurde dass demonstriert
wurde das gezeigt wurde dass der Begriff
der Nachhaltigkeit eigentlich aus der
Forstwirtschaft kommt das nachhaltigkeit
bedeutet eine nachhaltige Nutzung dass
man bald dass man Holz auch nutzt dass
wir schützen und nutzen das ist doch der
eigentliche Begriff von Nachhaltigkeit
dazu stehen wir und eins noch zum Holz
jeder der jeder Raum Mieter Brennholz
nachhaltig genutzt das ist 130 Liter
Heizöl und über 100 Kubikmeter Erdgas
das entspricht 350 Kilogramm CO2 und
trägt zum Klimaschutz bei meine Damen
und Herren
und jetzt und jetzt feiert sich die FDP
dass sie im Bereich Holz unter Umständen
ein Problem gelöst hat wir wissen es
noch nicht dass es ohne Ampel nie
gegeben hätte meine Damen und Herren
das ist doch die Zahl
biomasse-tech momentan laut bmwk laut
bmwk selbst zu über 80% der Erneuerbaren
Wärmeproduktion in Deutschland bei und
wir als Union stehen zu einer
nachhaltigen Holz zu einer nachhaltigen
Biomasse Nutzung insgesamt meine Damen
und Herren viele
viele ihre Änderungen die Sie jetzt nach
hartnäckigen Protesten andeuten hätten
sie viel früher haben können wenn sie
entsprechend auf Fachleute auf
Handwerker aus der Branche gehört hätten
wenn sie mit Waldbesitzern wenn sie mit
Förstern gesprochen hätten wenn sie ihr
Gesetz einen praxischeck unterzogen
hätten nach dem Versuch
nach ihrem Versuch zuerst die kleine
Wasserkraft abzuschalten nach ihren
ihrer vermurkten gasumlage nach einem
planlosen Kernkraftwerk Ausstieg nun das
Gebäude Energiegesetz das heizungsgesetz
das auch völlig vermutlich war die
ampelschaft Skifahren überhaupt keine
Lösungen sondern es lediglich Teil des
Problems meine Damen und Herren
und nach wie vor nach wie vor ist völlig
offen wie die entsprechende
Förderkulisse ausziehen soll nach wie
vor ist völlig offen was eigentlich
diese Leitplanken bedeuten Leitplanken
braucht man übrigens nur wenn man in
Schleudern geraten ist wie die Ampel im
Moment und nach wie vor ist auch der
Ablauf völlig unklar und wenn sie sagen
wir brauchen eigentlich normalerweise
eine kommunale Planung wärmeplanung
zuerst wieso verabschieden sie dann
nicht zuerst es kommen Gesetz zur
kommunalen Wahl wärmeplanung und dann
entsprechend in Ruhe das Gebäude
Energiegesetz sie schaffen weiter
massive bei unsicherung und wir werden
sie dabei genau beobachten um
entsprechend vielleicht doch nur
funktionale Lösungen zu finden
herzlichen Dank
die erste Lesung des Gebäude
Energiegesetzes hier im Deutschen
Bundestag durchaus eine erregte Debatte
über Phasen nächste Rednerin jetzt
stellvertreten Fraktionsvorsitzender SPD
einen Schritt mitzugehen der schon
längst hätte passieren müssen nämlich in
Richtung wärmewende in diesem Land
nämlich so sieht es aus
und ja wir werden jetzt schrittweise
dieses Gebäude Energiegesetz wie der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister eben skizziert
hat mit der kommunalen wärmeplanung
verzahnen wir bauen erst das Fundament
und dann wird darauf aufgebaut und das
individuelle kommt wenn das
gemeinschaftliche steht und wir haben
natürlich zugehört
zu und bei den Debatten in diesem Land
und es ist nun mal kein Thema was die
Menschen derzeit so bewegt wie die
Heizungen und Jens Spahn wenn sie
fordern
Vertrauen in die Demokratie muss doch
gegeben sein indem die Dinge schon mal
direkt klar sind wir sagen wir hören zu
und wir trauen uns auch als Ampel zu
diesen Diskurs und diese Fragen und die
Bedenken der Menschen ernst zu nehmen
uns zusammen hinzusetzen und zu sagen
wir ringen um die besten Lösungen und da
wo drei Partner zusammen um Lösungen
Ringen da reibt es sich mal da entsteht
aber auch Wärme und da wird ein gutes
Gesetz am Ende des Tages auch bei
rumkommen
und Herren wenn sie sagen wir möchten
keine Demonstrationen mehr dann frage
ich mich in welcher Demokratie wollen
Sie denn eigentlich leben ich bin sehr
dankbar dass man in Deutschland
demonstrieren kann seine Stimme erheben
kann und dass wir eben auch Dinge ernst
nehmen und hier miteinander auf ein
gutes Verfahren eingehen und wir haben
heute die erste Lesung ich finde da kann
erstmal jeder wieder durchatmen da
können wir uns jetzt überlegen wie
kommen wir denn gut ans Ziel klar ist
wir müssen handeln klar ist wir werden
das über die Kommunen ganz konkret vor
Ort tun mit Fernwärme mit vielleicht
doch Wasserstoff wenn er in der
Industrie nicht überall gebraucht wird
mit aber auch einer Vernetzung über die
Postleitzahl hinaus deswegen wird es
eine flächendeckende wärmeplanung geben
wir werden die Quartiere vernetzen wir
nehmen auch die Hinweise aus dem
Bundesrat ernst aber ja ich habe
wahrgenommen sie sind überfordert wenn
es nicht darum geht einfach nur stumpf
Unterschriften zusammen und hier eine
Debatte nicht kon struktiv zu begleiten
sondern aufzuheizen so ist es nämlich
und ja das sind verschiedene Interessen
die wir zusammenführen Matthias mir
Schatz eben ganz klar gesagt wofür die
Sozialdemokratie schon immer stand und
schon immer stehen wird für gute
Lösungen zwischen Klimaschutz zwischen
sozialen Komponenten nämlich so dass wir
alle mitnehmen und niemanden
zurücklassen und da ist es mir ganz ganz
wichtig dass wir bei Mieterschutz auch
was Gutes hinbekommen dass wir auf der
einen Seite dafür sorgen dass die
Vermieter in gute klimaneutrale
Heizungen investieren dass der Staat das
ganze mit fördert und die Mieterinnen
und Mieter am Ende des Tages nicht
überfordert werden und das ist eben
dieser Dreiklang den wir jetzt in diesem
gesetzgeberischen Verfahren mit aller
Ernsthaftigkeit auch lösen und in den
Fokus dieser Verhandlungen auch Stellen
Frau Huberts gestatten Sie eine Frage
oder zwischen Bemerkung aus der
afd-fraktion von Herrn hillse also ich
möchte dass die Bruder Debatte hier
nicht noch weiter sinken wie sie es eben
schon getan haben nein
und ja wir werden uns auch die
Förderkulisse noch mal ganz genau
anschauen denn diese Wende dieser Wandel
der muss finanzierbar sein und deswegen
haben wir auch eine Formulierung
getroffen dass wir soziale Härten bis in
die Mitte der Gesellschaft also das ganz
normale Leben der Familie vor Ort dass
wir das eben so gestalten finanziell mit
der Förderung dass auch jeder hier
mitkommen kann bei dem was wir vorhaben
und wir haben ja auch schon angedeutet
dass wir uns Alter vielleicht kein
Kriterium ist ich kenne sehr wohlhabende
82-Jährige ich kenne Menschen die sind
34 oder 53 und die stehen vor anderen
Herausforderungen also wir diskutieren
und debattieren hier sehr wohl sehr
verantwortlich in diesem Verfahren um
die beste Lösung
und auf Rheinland-Pfalz kommen kann ich
sagen wir sind das weitreichste
Bundesland deswegen war es uns als SPD
auch immer wichtig dass wir das Heizen
mit Holz und mit Pellets natürlich
weiterhin ermöglichen weil ein Teil der
wärmewende der wächst auch bei uns ja
auf den heimischen würden aber da muss
ich nicht mit dem Atlantik Tanker hier
im Süd brasilianischen Raum irgendwas
Abholzen da kann man es ja auch noch
darum dass wir da eine gute Lösung
miteinander hinbekommen
summa summarum bedeutet es wir gehen
jetzt einen Weg los und wir laden Sie
ganz herzlich ein die nächsten Wochen
hier mit uns auch konstruktiv zu
verhandeln die Menschen brauchen
Sicherheit sie brauchen
Planungssicherheit und sie brauchen
einen Planeten auf dem man irgendwann
auch mal noch ein Häusle bauen kann aber
sie denken natürlich viel zu kurzfristig
und deswegen lassen Sie uns doch lieber
mal hier das Handwerkliche Zeug denn wir
finden hier eine gute Lösung für dieses
Land herzlichen Dank
die stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende der SPD verbreitet
hier Zuversicht in der Tat ambitioniert
noch drei Wochen sind Zeit viele viele
Fragen sind offen und ein Text gibt's
doch nicht Hilfe mit einer
Kurzintervention von der AFD kommt er
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin dass sie
die kurze Prävention zulassen Werte
Kollegin ich hätte eigentlich nur zwei
Fragen gehabt wobei hat sich jetzt zum
Schluss noch eine weitere Frage ergeben
ich komme aus der Nähe von Hoyerswerda
dort gibt es weil es ein großes
Neubaugebiet gibt auch ein Fernwärmenetz
die sind ja dann quasi von diesen
Regelungen ausgeschlossen bzw befreit
dieses Fernwärmenetz wird betrieben vom
gaskombination vom von Schwarze Pumpe
und Kraftwerk Schwarze Pumpe und die
Feiern mit Kohle wenn man jetzt also
ganz ganz also wenn man CO2 ganz ganz
als als sehr sehr schlimm ansieht als
sehr sehr böse ansieht das machen sie ja
was ist jetzt quasi der Sinn darin dass
jemand verboten bekommt eine Gasheizung
einzubauen die also weniger schlimmes
böses CO2 ausstößt und dafür dann aber
sozusagen versorgt wird mit einem über
einen Fernwärmenetz was mit Kohle
betrieben wird und jetzt noch mal die
zweite Ungereimtheit die ich gerne von
ihm beantwortet haben möchte
sie haben gerade gesagt ist macht also
keinen Sinn Holz quasi über den Atlantik
zu schippern um es dann hier zu
verfeuern aber mit dem LG Gas ist das
dessen was anderes also weil wir könnten
eigentlich leitungsgebundenes Gas
bekommen zumindest in einem gewissen
Teil oder wir könnten auch Schiefergas
fracking-gas in Deutschland selber
fördern
das könnten wir das wäre zweimal bzw
ungefähr nur halb so teuer wie das
Energien würde natürlich viel viel
weniger Emissionen verursachen weil
natürlich die Tanker die im Moment vor
Rügen z.B da war ich gerade die Menschen
sind da sehr verunsichert das sollten LG
Terminal hingebaut werden sollen mit
Schweröl über den Ozean schippern also
da gibt es ein paar Ungereimtheiten wenn
sie nicht aufklären könnten wäre es mir
sehr recht
Frau Robert möchten Sie antworten
vielleicht haben sie mitbekommen dass
Ministerin Davids Minister Habeck dazu
einen Gipfel schon veranstaltet haben
denn natürlich müssen auch diese Netze
CO2 neutral werden aber wir können uns
das Land ja nicht CO2 neutral zaubern
deswegen heißt es ja auch Transformation
und diesen Weg gehen wir los
und ja ich würde am liebsten auch kein
lng-gas über den Atlantik schippern aber
sie haben ja vielleicht auch mitbekommen
dass da eine Pipeline nicht mehr
verfügbar ist dass wir schnell in einer
Krise Handeln mussten und da fehlt
manchmal auch eine Möglichkeit und
deswegen müssen wir eben auch da Wege
gehen die nicht die präferiertesten sind
und konstruktive Lösungen in kriegs- und
Krisenzeiten erfordern eben umso mehr
Zusammenhalt und dass man auch mal Wege
geht die man nicht gehen würde und
deswegen ist das hier mit abschließend
beantwortet
nächster Redner in dieser Debatte für
die cdu/csu-fraktion DR Jan Marco
Lutscher
für Wohnen Stadtentwicklung Bauwesen und
Kommunen der cocsu-bundestagsfraktion
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich möchte noch
gerne einmal zurückkommen auf den
Kollegen müssen sie haben ja der Union
jetzt gerade vorgeworfen in ihrer Rede
dass wir mit unserer Kritik an ihrem
Verfahren dass wir dazu beitragen die
Menschen zu verunsichern dass wir dazu
beitragen würden die Menschen dem
rechten Rand der AFD zuzutreiben da habe
ich jetzt alles Verständnis für herrscht
dass sie Fraktionsvorsitzender der SPD
werden wollen und sie hier ein bisschen
auftrumpfen müssen da habe ich ein
bisschen Verständnis für aber wir
sollten doch schon bei der Wahrheit hier
bleiben und Ursache und Wirkung nicht
verwechseln meine Damen und Herren es
ist in ihrer Koalition gewesen die ein
völlig verkorktes Gesetz vorgelegt hat
was ideologisch überladen war was eben
gerade nicht wie die Grünen gesagt haben
irgendwie nur technisch sich mit
Heizungen beschäftigt hat sondern was
die Menschen ganz existenziell betroffen
hat und es war ihre Koalition die da
wochenlang darüber gestritten hat es war
ihre Koalition die das dann durch
Kabinett gepeitzert obwohl völlig klar
war dass es überhaupt gar keine
Einigkeit keine Mehrheit in dieser
Koalition gab und sie haben dann mit
ihrer Koalition weiter gestritten und
jetzt ein zwei dünne Seiten Leitplanken
vorgeworfen und schmeißen uns das jetzt
vor die Füße und erwarten dass wir das
bis zur Sommerpause in drei Wochen
durchpeitschen wo kein Abgeordneter kein
Experte bei der Anhörung sich überhaupt
seriös damit beschäftigen kann wissen
sie was sie machen deine Simulation von
parlamentarischer Demokratie nichts
anderes
und das einzig Richtige wäre das einzige
richtige wäre wenn Sie diesen
Gesetzentwurf zurückziehen würden aber
dazu fehlt ihnen der Mut und ich sage
Ihnen auch weswegen ihm der Mutter zu
führen damit der Wirtschaftsminister
sein Gesicht waren kann und weil sie
Angst haben vor dem Landtagswahlen die
im Herbst kommen weil sie den Streit
nicht weiterführen wollen der Koalition
sie stellen ihre Partei Interessen als
Ampel über die Interessen der Menschen
und des Landes meine Damen und Herren
und was mich besonders ärgert an der
Stelle der Bundeskanzler der hat in den
letzten Wochen wo erbittert gestritten
wurde wie so ein Unbeteiligte daneben
gestanden als ob er damit überhaupt
nichts zu tun hätte als ob er keine
Richtlinie Kompetenz hätte und damit hat
er zu Eskalation beigetragen dieses
Streites damit hat er dazu beigetragen
dass die Menschen in unserem Land
hunderttausende zutiefst verunsichert
gewesen sind wissen Sie was diese
Führungslosigkeit dieser Koalition das
ist ein Armutszeugnis meine Damen und
Herren
und dann geht's noch weiter ich habe ja
in Ordnung dass die Seeheimer sich
treffen beim Spargel essen in der Sonne
treffen aber dass der Bundeskanzler ich
kann mir das gut vorstellen mit dem Glas
Weißwein in der Hand hinstellen mit
einem Residenten manche sagen mit einem
schlumpfigen Lächeln sagt naja es hat so
ein bisschen geruckelt wissen Sie was
ein bisschen geruckelt dafür dass die
Menschen existenzielle
Ängste haben dass sie sich in ihrem
Lebenswerk bedroht sind und auf die
Straße gehen eine solche äußere hat ein
bisschen geruckelt das finde ich sowas
in dem platziert und unangemessen meine
Damen und Herren
und dass die FDP sich jetzt hier
hinstellt ja war ja heute in der
Frankfurter Allgemeinen Zeitung zu lesen
dass da eine triumphstimmung herrscht
wir sind mit 100% in die Verhandlung
hineingegangen wir sind mit 100%
rauskommen sie liebe Kolleginnen und von
der FDP sie haben überhaupt keinen Grund
für siegesdorf denn sie sind
mitverantwortlich für dieses chaotische
Verfahren es war ihr Minister der das
Kabinett gepeichert obwohl er wusste
dass es keine Mehrheit gibt diese
Protokollerklärung die abgegeben hat das
war eine Bank Erklärung und nichts
anderes
und wenn sie jetzt in der Sache sagen in
der Sache sagen es gebe jetzt gar keine
Eingriffe mehr ins Eigentum im Bestand
sondern funktionierende Heizung die
können ohne Einschränkungen weiter
betrieben werden da muss ich mal sagen
dann lesen Sie mal das
interpretationspapier der Grünen da
steht genau das Gegenteil drin natürlich
können Eigentümer eine Gasheizung
einbauen ja das können Sie aber wenn
später eine Dame Planung kommt die kein
wasserstoffnetz wurde dann müssen Sie
diese Heizung die tadellos funktioniert
wieder rausreißen das ist ja wohl
ziemlich der massivste Eingriff ins
Eigentum geben kann liebe Kolleginnen
und deswegen gibt es für dieses
gesetzeswagen nur eine einzige
Möglichkeit ziehen Sie das Gesetz zurück
machen sie einen ordentliches Gesetz und
beenden Sie diese unsägliche
Verunsicherung die Sie in dieses Land
mit diesem Gesetz tragen meine Damen und
Herren
mittlerweile hat Katrin Göring-Eckardt
hier die brasilienstelle besetzt und die
letzte Rednerin bei der Gebäude in beim
Gebäude Energiegesetz erste Lesung wird
von der SPD kommen Nina schädlich
Sprecherin für Klimaschutz und Energie
der SPD-Fraktion
der liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen Herr
lutschak ist es immer wieder
erschütternd was für
Ablenkungsmanöver hier sieht zelebrieren
es hat nichts mit wärmewende zu tun was
von ihren ihrer Fraktion zu unternehmen
ist rein gar nichts
in der ganzen Debatte hat allein Andreas
Jung ein ein Element von Energiepolitik
in den Mund genommen und dabei aber
vermissen lassen wie das denn alles
sozialgerecht ausgestaltet werden soll
wie das denn funktionieren soll sie
setzen auf marktwirtschaftliche Lösungen
wissen ganz genau dass der Markt alleine
der Markt massive Ungleichheiten erzeugt
das ist vielfach belegt und dann hört
man immer wieder durch es sollte ja
eigentlich nur um irgendwelche
Verlängerung von manchen von manchen
Kraftwerken gehen man hört zunehmend
durch dass es ihnen doch wieder um den
Einstieg in die Atomenergie geht sagen
Sie mir doch mal wie soll denn wenn
weltweit kein einziges Atomkraftwerk und
subjunktioniert funktioniert und läuft
wie soll denn dann bitteschön dies
funktionieren wenn sie doch angeblich
nur die marktwirtschaftlichen Lösung
wollen das stimmt hinten und vorne nicht
zusammen und sie lassen auch vermissen
wurden bitteschön die wärmewende nämlich
der Umstieg auf erneuerbare Energien
dann bleibt wo bleibt das denn sie haben
als einzigen konstruktiven Vorschlag aus
diesen rein heute nur das eine gebracht
dass wir doch bitte dieses Gesetz
vertragen sollen das ist das einzige was
sie zu wärmewendet zu sagen haben
Licht und spricht für sich
wir haben mit dem Verfahren was jetzt
angesetzt wurde mit den Leitplanken die
verständigt wurden anders als sie
unterstellen sehr wohl ein starkes Pfund
für also pro zugunsten eines
parlamentarischen verfahrensgesetz denn
diesmal ist noch bevor eine Anhörung
stattgefunden hat noch bevor die
stattfindet allen Expertinnen und
Experten die eingeladen sind klar welche
Prämissen wir in dieses Verfahren
gesetzt haben das ist häufig nicht der
Fall und häufig haben wir sehr kurze
Verfahren weil einfach die
allbedürftigkeit das auch von uns
abverlangt das haben wir auch Parlamente
aus häufig schon kritisiert manchmal
gibt es eine Bedürftigkeiten die uns die
die die wir nicht beeinflussen können
aber das ist natürlich immer genau der
menschliche Punkt dass wir dann
Anhörungen haben und dann hinterher noch
große Änderung haben sie auch immer
wieder kritisiert dass dann diese
Änderungen ja relativ kurzfristig vor
der zweiten dritten Lesung kommen jetzt
haben wir große
änderungsverständigung schon vor der
Anhörung thematisiert das ist in welche
Richtung die Änderungen gehen und dann
sagen Sie das Gehen in ginge gegen den
Parlamentarismus das ist doch genau das
Gegenteil die haben jetzt die Chance in
den Anhörungen und die Experten wissen
das natürlich und die reflektieren immer
die öffentliche Debatte genau darauf
einzugehen und wir setzen in den
Mittelpunkt wir setzen in den
Mittelpunkt des parlamentarischen
Verfahrens dass wir eine Ermöglichung
der wärmewende bekommen die Ermöglichung
wird in den Mittelpunkt gestellt und die
Ermöglichung verlangen natürlich dass
wir die Reihenfolge ändern dass die
kommunale wärmewende das kommunale
wärmewende realisiert wird und das dann
in Anpassung an die kommunale wärmewende
dann alles weitere passiert alles andere
wäre nicht effektiv alles andere würde
Zeit verschwenden alles andere würde
auch Gelder verschenken und genau diese
Reihenfolge haben wir jetzt
implementiert durch das parlamentarische
wirken und genau diese Verzahnung wird
natürlich auch bei dem
werbeplanungsgesetz berücksichtigt auch
das wurde festgehalten das ist keine
Feuchtigkeiten gibt es ist ebenfalls
festgehalten dass keiner im Stich
gelassen wird natürlich wird in der
Ausgestaltung darauf Wert gelegt und
nicht nur Wert wie so eine umgesetzt
dass die Mieterinnen und Mieter nicht
überfordert werden auch darüber gibt es
eine Einigung insofern ist es auch
falsch wenn unterstellt wird das hier
etwas vergessen worden wäre was
natürlich wichtig ist wir müssen wenn
wir die Ermöglichung wollen natürlich
auch die finanziellen Grundlagen
schaffen das wird doch ein weiterer
großer Bereich auf dem wir uns
verständigen müssen und über den sie
jetzt nicht mehr sprechen können
erwähnen aber es ist
wirklich wenn hier keine Distanzierung
von den verheerenden Aussagen von
Personen in Erding die Kollegen Seiten
kommt sie können sich die Bezugnahme
nehmen auf diese Ereignis ohne sich
bewegen
damit schieße ich die Aussprache für
heute auch wenn ich davon ausgehe dass
sie Debatten weitergehen werden aber
jedenfalls nicht mehr in dieser
Tagesordnung interfraktionell wird
Überweisung der Vorlagen auf Drucksachen
68 75 und 72 26 an die Ausschüsse
vorgeschlagen die sie in der
Tagesordnung finden damit sind
offensichtlich alle einverstanden dann
verfahren wir so